beethoven's idea was that art is not the
essential tool but perhaps the tool in
order to acquire what is higher in
ourself I believe still in that bit of
music can help us to make a better
society
if quote-unquote art oh yeah and had
mentioned that art can help us to
elevate us from being what we also are
through opening a kind of metaphysical
dimension is that something you can
describe or not I think art we are
talking about music and art and which
means that we're deeply committed to it
it's part of our lives
and because it's part of our lives we
want it to be part of other people's
lives too and people who it is not part
of their lives to such an extent at
present consequently as will said the
perception of her heart and its possible
meanings and the ambiguities of music
which George referred to so beautifully
all these things are a basis for
education we want to offer people the
best they can't necessarily always
accept it no they were the best of what
the best of what can be done by
perpetual concern with what are in fact
the great masterpieces of art the
classics is I don't know right when he
states that Beethoven was replaced by
Hitler the course dare no longer existed
a profound experience of art because
that is what he says
if they really would have this
I mean Hartman is something you just
said yourself if people really listened
this would not have happened who can I
take the floor Margaret
he can't be right I don't think because
the people he talked about had those
sort of upbringing they listened to
their parents playing and they
themselves had a profound appreciation
of German culture but they went many of
them to work in our suits and Dachau I
mean to say that this lack that there
was a vacuum I don't think there was and
it seems to be owed or no was very wise
and very often very right but this one I
can't agree with and and it seems to be
one of the great historical puzzles of
the 20th century which were still
grappling with is how could this
immensely civilize country this country
where the arts were so valued where
every town had its own concert hall
where you have wonderful opera where you
had terrific science I mean this was a
highly educated and civilized population
and it seems to me that the question
which was still grappling with this how
could it how could it have happened
there how could not Susan have taken
over but to say that it's an absence of
coach who seems to me just not to make
sense I would argue that perhaps in his
example is wrong but in a principle he's
right because you have this phrase of
him the lack of experience of this
humanistic spirit he instantiated it
with this tradition of playing at home
music which is an excellent German
tradition now extinct but it might be
like his example is wrong but could you
deny Margaret that this lack of
experience of the humanistic spirit is
at the very root of the brutality of the
nahji regime which Germany was esteemed
to be the most cultivated country in
Europe and the that the greatest babari
came out of that why because something
was missing and doorknob put it is this
experience of the
monastic spirit not only to be
cultivated in order to have knowledge or
to be knowledgeable or to have
information but to have something in in
in addition which was the soul the soul
of it
they simply substitute one authority by
another but the spirit of obedience
doesn't change first we look to a genius
Beethoven for leadership as you seem to
do rob and then all of a sudden we say
no now we have better than that we have
Hitler will do whoever and then after a
bad experience we come back to Beethoven
what greener grass is saying this is the
typical attitude of the lower middle
class they should decide for themselves
and not look up to some authority to
some genius to some tight and artist to
some high art or ever to tell them what
to do
but they should take responsibility for
themselves and don't hang anybody's
picture on the wall and look up to it
idea that George Steiner was talking
about earlier of music being ambiguous
that the very root of it being ambiguous
um I think is actually essential to our
understanding of what happened in what
we might call the most advanced
civilized culture musically that we've
had in the world and how it turned into
barbarism to suggest that the ideas in
music are really not helpful but the
emot-- I mean we can think about the
ideas or we like but the idea that music
hits emotion and it hits it very hard
and hits the nervous system in places
that nothing else does and it creates
longings that themselves are ambiguous
and can reach in several ways one
towards good towards the highest goal of
mankind towards being in the world in
the most proper and idealistic way
but it can also reach towards ideas of
land of belonging of your group of a
place that was once your as a place that
must be yours again the notes rising and
you suddenly feel actually where's my
knife where is my bomb where's my gun
and for someone beside you is feeling
where's my love for as my love for as my
love and that the audience to people can
feel emotion with the same notes being
played and the emotion will lead them in
two completely separate directions and
we have to take that as basic and as
short and as understood and to think
that somehow if we only if the person
beside us who's thinking about Bavaria
or Ireland or Afghanistan just isn't
listening right if only they could
listen better like I listen then the
world would be a better place or if the
music could be played properly for them
no it seems to me basic in the ideas of
emotion and especially in that ease of
emotion surrounding nationalism that
music can hit that emotion that gives
rise to nationalism and in a way that
very little else can in a way that in a
way speeches can't or legislation can't
and this the song The Ballad Beethoven's
you know work with Irish Irish music
Beethoven's higher music all of that can
hit the person beside you in a way which
can make them intolerant intolerable and
violent and can make you the very best
you can be it's in the music it's it's
basic is essential